four minutes we're going to move we get
them moving now there's two video we
don't stand a chance if we stay here
let's move out let's get you out of here
sweetie
all right boys right now you're gonna
take your trenches Troy you and a dash
of the second tier keep channel three
open communication
get your [ __ ] game faces on boys we
move on my mark
[Music]
no clear
[Music]
where are you
[Music]
Lucifer
copy I have visual you've got one hit
laying down fire directly in front of
your position looks like there's an
oral-b room we could provide a
distraction multiple things approaching
from the back [ __ ] we got an emptiness
[Applause]
and I'm sick I repeat
[Music]
ah [ __ ] that was already that we have to
edit foot snare strike killing any
second now
get ready to move
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh cover the door I'll clear the room
it's clear
[Music]
Cynthia Connie
Zach do you copy Jesus Christ were eBay
what's world is going mystery
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]